i want to do this first because what i
want to talk about critical theory and
general critical gender theory
the big battle in loudoun county is
actually over a transgender policy bill
so it's not just race theory
but i got to i got i got to pull up this
book i was looking at this book we got
this
how to be an anti-racist by ibram x
candy
ultimate summary lessons goals checklist
and action plans is made press so
what is this what is this insane book so
this is a book that you
use while you read his book that fairfax
county virginia for example spent 24 000
buying and requiring children to read
and so then you get this workbook that
accompanies it and you would have loved
it right you would have just filled in
the blank you would have said oh okay i
have to go
this is my next prompt you would have
been a great student going through this
workbook
so tell us some of the great questions
that they've got in there well i want to
go to the to the let's go let's go to
the back let's see what we got
okay um those are action steps
first i'll just point out they have
these these areas where you can write
lessons number one queer racism is a
strong collection of racist policies
leading to inequity among race
sexualities
that can be substantiated by racist
ideas as regards
race sexualities queer anti-racism is
the phenomenal gathering of anti-racist
policies
leading to equity amongst race
sexualities for authentication by
anti-racist ideas on race sexualities
every race sexuality is unique did that
mean anything i feel like i missed a
step yeah i missed something it's
what's happening sexuality answer the
question
yes yeah it's so intentional word salad
because they want to confuse people and
make them dizzy with
their assumptions they have so many
strange assumptions in every sentence
here's here's one in what ways can you
be a successful gender and queer
anti-racist
yeah exactly like what what yeah and
then you just fill the blanket yeah fill
the blanket
explain why everything about race is
tied to lay down policies that
predominantly cause so much harm to
other racial groups
wait wait hold on what explain why
everything about race is
tied to lay down policies that
predominantly cause so much harm to
other racial groups
what what what is he saying is he saying
that
his own book about race
is harming racial groups or is he saying
that the restricting it cause harms to
racial groups
like he needs a copy editor yeah
seriously
here's your goals in number one and you
got to write you got to fill this in
in what ways has your sexuality been
threatened how did you go about it and
what would you have done differently
what what
what how old are the kids who get this
these kids will be high schoolers okay
okay
i mean still come yeah oh yeah it's it's
basically
you're getting this bible for critical
race theory hand it to these kids for a
required reading and then you're getting
his own nonsense repeated back as if
you're supposed to treat it like it's
intelligent prompt it's garbled nonsense
i mean yeah so here's another one
and again you got to fill out the blank
map out the modus operandi
you intend to begin in helping to
protect and shield vulnerable
homosexuals and heterosexuals henceforth
wow yeah is that what high school kids
need yes and so what's what's the hidden
agenda there
it is to turn our kids from being
students
of knowledge into activists yes i mean
that's the bottom line teachers have
said that i love this
chapter 16 failure it says race is a
social construct not a power construct
what yes racist racial history
as a singular match of racial progress
and not a combat of anti-racist and
racist progress
did you say racist racial history yes
this is terrible
right racist problem being ingrained in
ignorance and hatred and not powerful
selfish interests
it says the racial history of failure is
tied to failed solutions and policies
the failed solutions and policies are
due to failed racial principles
there are several wrong notions of race
we need to debunk before we go further
this is circular it feels like a fever
dream have you guys ever
had like strep throat you wake up in the
middle right right right
exactly things don't make sense but if
you can believe like so
he's become the poster boy for this
right he's being
uh twenty thousand dollars for one hour
zoom call
you ready for this one the school
districts pay this is what they're
asking children they're
they're asking okay maybe the teenagers
yeah
why do you think the black skin makes
non-black uncomfortable
i read that verbatim by the way the
black skin yeah makes non-black
uncomfortable
yeah non this is this is like robin
d'angelo
it is when she said she wrote what did
she write in her book that she was like
she went to a party with black people
and she felt really uncomfortable around
them
i'm like that's you dude yeah yeah
that's not a me problem and then if you
have an in
if you've internalized some messages
about yourself
like don't go projecting them on others
and all they do is projects
yeah yeah and so there's i what i'm so
happy about
is so many of the black parents that are
emerging and saying this is not what how
how we want to raise our kids like
they're in loudoun they're in fairfax
there's there's a great movement there
are you a behavioral racist
or anti-racist and what are your
attributes based on your chosen position
yeah you're either a racist or nancy
racist oh so it says are you a or b
and after you select that yes you are
one of the two
yeah no but here's here's the point both
racist and anti-racist
believe in discriminating on the basis
of race yeah there's no anti-racism from
extended is we must it's it's in even
mexican has called for racial
discrimination yes yeah he has that
quote where he said the only solution to
past discrimination
is present discrimination and future
discrimination i'm paraphrasing right
so to tell kids you are either a racist
or an anti-racist and they have to pick
one
he they're basically creating this false
choice where it's like
well so which one do you want to be do
you want to be the person who
discriminates in the base of race
or do you want to be the person who
discriminates in a basis of race sure
yeah a
mom was just telling me that this is
just like the salem witch trials
you know as i was driving here are you a
witch oh then we have to burn you at the
stake oh you're not a witch then that
means you're denying being a witch
and then we're gonna burn you no then we
have to drop you in the water and see if
you float
right right exactly so either way you
died yeah yeah either way and that's
what they're going after they
are trying to destroy people this is a
lovely notebook
that you can inspire your blm notebook
is this just like for writing
yes just for your your personal
reflections yeah
so this right here this fist is called
the red salute
right yeah and it's been appropriated
they call it the black power fist
and that's like saying it's not the nazi
salute it's the white power salute it's
like i don't care what you call it dude
it represents
authoritarian identitarianism i'm not
interested and then this is now this
this fist is now becoming the stuff of
powerpoint slides and classrooms it's
the stuff of posters in teachers rooms
it's it just goes it and that's what
fascinates me propaganda again
because this becomes cool for the kids
that's not good somebody on twitter
pointed out to me that the feminist
symbol
is exactly the same fist but with you
know the sign for the feminine and i'm
like how long has this been going
on right how did we not notice right so
there's a bunch of other books what's
this call me max book you have
oh yeah so this goes into the
transgender issue so this was a book
that was read to
kids right in austin texas in the school
district there
called ins and um lovely pages about a
well i don't know i mean do you call a
girl
who a boy born a girl who is
wants to be called max and he takes i
mean max is
actually um could go androgynous yeah so
maxine he declares that
his parents had decided at birth
that he was a girl but he decided no
i am not the grown-ups made a mistake
and so lovely max is able to
find little kids that he can speak to
about it
and then fortunately for him he finds a
friend
who is also in the same situation
and has decided that he's a girl and
a support group at school and
there they get to talk about their
identity issues
away from the parents who were wrong yes
who were wrong and made a mistake
that's what and so a really critical
part of these teachings
including this one i am jazz another
famous one
right is that the parents made a mistake
so this is again another marxist ideal
this is from the cultural revolution
right dividing the parents from the
children
yes creating intergenerational warfare
and ultimately the state knows better
than the parent on how to raise a child
do you remember when the teachers were
melting down over the idea that parents
could now listen to their classes with
zoom
oh yeah i know and that's why and yeah
because ultimately
that in this whole dynamic
is the idea that the kids have secrets
also
that they need to keep from the parents
so you know this is another issue where
school districts are debating whether or
not a child comes to them
and they say they want to be called by a
different pronoun
do they tell the parents and then they
have a form
on whether or not they tell the parents
or not because they can keep it the
secret from the parents
wow yeah yeah i have some questions
about uh
books i was just looking through the
book and in it the the child eventually
you know talking to the kids at school
goes to the parents the parents have a
conversation
then the kid goes to a support group
what about
children who are pre-bubescent what what
about them is
not boy or girl right so they say that
uh
gender is a social construct so is the
issue that
max which could be a male or female name
uh
max wants to wear blue jeans and not a
skirt well that's not
anything to do with biological sex i
agree whether or not someone wears a
skirt is a social construct in scotland
they wear kilts
very similar in some respects yeah
middle east yeah in the middle east they
wear
uh what would you call them the gowns
basically right
yeah men wearing guys right right yeah
uh a toga that's a burning man i wore a
dress
normal no so so while they say that
gender
social construct the way we dress as a
social construct a child who has no
concept of sexuality
would go through a biological treatment
when what they're really saying is i
want to wear different clothing yeah so
there's a lot of questions around that
yeah and then
what's happening is our medical system
is now creating
firewalls between parents and children
when the kid turns 13
so that they can have private
conversations with their health care
provider
away from the parent i've evergreen one
of these school
these health care systems in seattle has
just announced that 13 year olds get
their own email address
to talk to their healthcare provider so
that they can have these private
conversations
so you're saying so the schools and the
medical providers are
are encouraging kids to talk about
gender issues they're having changing
their gender and not
tell the parents yeah specifically if
they don't tell the parents
yeah because what the narrative is is
that the parents are evil
that they bully that they are not
understanding and that they
create then transphobia right so they
use all of their words
then against the parents to create all
of these
systems that separate children from
their parents
is this um you said they're just trying
to get this passed in the school system
where
it's happening it's happening i just
read virginia's
new policies you know they've gotten rid
of the uh father-daughter dance
because that's not okay anymore so i
just want to
i'll stress this point one more time
before we jump to this this next
relevant story is
if someone a child who has not gone
through puberty
has no experience of sexuality
how would that child understand they
want to undergo a biological process
to to be or not be it's it's it's
i don't know i i guess the argument it's
a similar argument the left uses
one of the arguments we've seen from
many uh of the uh pro trans
activists is that if a child doesn't
is going to go through say male puberty
they don't know what it's like to go
through male puberty maybe they wouldn't
like it therefore
they have actually argued that all
children should be put on hormone
blockers
until they can choose right right right
and
what what they what they fail to
understand is that there's actually uh
you know pre-prenatal testosterone plays
a huge role as well
and a child looking at dolls and action
figures and dresses and blue jeans
those are not that there's nothing to do
with your biological sex
but they want kids to undergo a physical
biological treatment
for a clothing or cultural issue yeah
and what's so disturbing to me is that
you know
growing up in india um and then visiting
there there's always been a difficult
relationship with folks who are
transgender
and i always had great empathy and oh
and still do to this day of course i
think most people do
with anybody who is you know in this
world
like you want to live and let live the
problem here
is that this is an intrusion now right
into the lives of children into the
lives of families
the decisions of families because i want
everybody to be able to live peacefully
and without harm right we all do we
don't want any kind of
harassment discrimination bullying but
this is a new propaganda that is
making it cool and making it getting
ideas and kids heads that they otherwise
wouldn't have because maybe they just
want to wear blue jeans
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you